gran y'know is a small town south of
Naples pasta is made here but not just
any pasta we make the best pasta in the
world
Arturo elefante could be described as
the rising star in the pasta firmament
gourmet is far and wide say he makes the
world's best pasta at pasta feet so they
can't be his working day starts above
the rooftops of Naples one of the key
ingredients is the weather we ought to
get 30 to 40% humidity today days like
this are good for the pasta Arturo
elefantes recipe for success combines
ideal weather conditions with local
ingredients such as durum wheat from the
next town sun sea water and the mountain
breeze make for ideal growing conditions
the wheat is delivered once a week
Arturo is working on a new variety of
pasta he uses a bronze perforated filter
to achieve the shape he wants the
machine saves me work so it doesn't take
as much effort that's not how it used to
be when we may pastor by hand we can put
out several times as much today the
biggest challenge is the dough the sole
ingredients water and durum wheat flour
are blended without air and the dough is
pushed through the filter under high
heat and pressure this is the first time
Arturo's made a big a long spiral shaped
pasta Italy is the world's largest pasta
producer at well over 3 million tons
annually
even if different forms are made from
the same dough other factors play a role
this is our Toros favorite variety
pasture shake can only be eaten with a
specific kind of sauce only with broth
and we ou need spaghetti with seafood
pasta is quintessentially Italian but
the oldest surviving noodle recipe came
from China it was written on parchment
nearly 4000 years ago the Greeks and
Romans discovered pasta early on tomb
images dating back to the 4th century BC
depict sacks of flour and rolling pins
the Arabs are credited with being the
first to drive fresh noodles so they
would keep our Toros pasta has to drive
for nearly 50 hours before it's packed
the factory turns out some 3 tons per
day that's me in the picture it's nice
to know my photo is going all around the
world everybody can see I'm the one who
made this pasta the moment of decision
has come Arturo's boss Jay Zebedee
Martino puts the new creation to the
taste test only if he gives it his
blessing will it go into production
you've done fabulous work he specifies
perfect color ideal shape nothing's left
stuck to the fork that pasta is
precisely al dente I do make the best
pastor in the world watch our train it's
to be sent to Don Alfonso a Michelin
star restaurant and one of the best in
Italy it's a family business over a
hundred years old a three-course meal
can cost some 200 euros
star chef Alfonso you kirino's recipe
for success
simple but high quality ingredients
today he'll be using Arturo's pasta in a
dish for the restaurants menu pasta has
this wonderful smell of wheat that's the
first thing I noticed now let's taste it
his idea is a straightforward dish of
olive oil pepperoncini and tuna will
Arturo's pasta make it onto the menu for
today the chef has no words he just
quietly enjoys it passes muster
compliments to the chef and compliments
to me it's a hit
Arturo elefantes pasta appears on the
menu of a two-star restaurant from a
small town just outside Naples it could
just be the world's best pasta
you